so it was very I'll say crucial for me
to do this interview in both English and
Creole because I see Creole languages
like even in the case of Haiti
especially because of Haiti as a
particular revealing and clear test tube
or key study to really show how language
can be such a powerful tool either for
illumination or for resistance either
for oppression or for development so I I
would love teachers who are watching
this this video and we look at the
course to see how they can adapt the
content in order to address similar
issues in the own community because I
think that what you see happening in the
Kazakh languages also happens in in the
u.s. appengine in in Europe in Latin
America in Africa where language is
often in use of this technology for
domination or resistance and I think
this course gives the some basic
analytical tools to be able to analyze
these patterns and and for me it's also
very important that teachers in Haiti
and Suez in Haiti including say you know
future leaders or policy makers get to
understand the discourse and the
readings and to understand that that
Haiti could do so much better if if
teachers students leaders had this
awareness of how the old attitudes
towards Creole versus French have played
over centuries in keeping the country in
the developed and if they could get a
better sense of the importance of
language in education development then I
think the country would do so much
better but for me it's a it's a it's a
key bottleneck that we have to go pass
in order to really be able to develop a
nation is to be is to be able to
understand the history and the nature of
your national your ancestral language
and to be able to use it in the most
systematic and water and productive way
if you cannot do that there is no way
that you can develop a whole nation that
speaks that language